[Music]  uh you get stats that are double digits  three times triple double yeah  something you do to your teammates when  they come off to come out the game high  five yeah you two good y'all need to  give us some harder cards uh what is it  uh eybl team paul pierce's nickname the  truth yeah uh what did nick's play uh  madison square garden uh  i was this kevin garnett's name like  nickname i don't know okay okay yeah  yeah that one was the big ticket i don't  know uh he's on tnt with my dad not  charles not ernie not my dad kenny yeah  the old nba video game all right nba  live  oh nba jam oh okay cool he does movies  he's at all the uh knicks games short  likely yeah yeah sorry spock didn't mean  to call you short uh it's first coach uh  papa yeah we running through these uh  turn over oh  when you give the ball away i basically  just said pass it nah you pass it  somebody steal it turn over yeah uh my  father chad